germany has been hit by heavy snow
and ice with disruption to public
transport likely to continue into monday
the northwestern state of lower saxony
had already seen heavy snow but so far
highways
haven't been severely affected as road
cleaning crews are managing to keep
up but some train services have been
cancelled the german weather service
says some parts of the country could see
anything from 15 to 40 centimeters of
snow
well correspondent jared reed is braving
that weather out in hanover forest in
central germany jared looking pretty
cold out there
the snow's just started coming down here
in berlin how's it looking where you are
well rebecca it's very cold here there's
a lot of snow that's fallen and there's
still a lot more snow to come
it's a tale of really extreme weather
across germany this weekend because
here in the north we're seeing very cold
temperatures being brought down by
an arctic a front being sent down from
the arctic
while in southern germany a warm a low
warm front is bringing a wetter warmer
weather so we have a situation where
there is an extreme difference in
temperatures between northern
and southern germany experts say this is
quite unusual and kind of where i
am is smack bang in the middle where
these two fronts are meeting and so we
have
very high levels of snow snow storms
very slippery roads and extreme
weather warnings for much of central and
northern germany this weekend
how much disruption is the storm causing
so far across the country
well emergency services have already
been very busy we've had reports of
over 200 car accidents on highways in
germany's most popular state
which is north rhine-westphalia in
germany's west
the train station behind me here in
hanover has
cancelled regional and long distance
trains and other cities have had to do
this as well they've had to cancel buses
what's what authorities have told
motorists here in lower saxony
is to prepare for black ice on the road
so
roads will be very slippery they're
telling people to
stay at home if they can and yeah
essentially
emergency services have their work cut
out for them this weekend
more staying at home then um so what are
the predictions
how long are the disruptions likely to
last
well whether authorities say that this
bad
bout of weather will continue into
monday but that it should
stop then but they are warning people
that it is going to remain
very very cold across much of northern
germany for the rest of the week oh dw's
jared reed
staying out there in the cold forest i'm
glad to be talking to you from the warm
studio jared stay warm
you